okay so
uh yesterday's problems with the punches
obviously had a lot to do that uh there
is no direct correlation between key on
and application okay because your main
problem is your mind
but
how sound your architecture is
about the ceiling of what you can do
with
your mind if you did solve that problem
okay so
when you start from just keyhole pure
keyhole
you have to keep in mind the problems
you were having yesterday against the
punches okay so for example i'm going to
be cognizant of that power line on the
shoulders
so we review the
the keyhole for the mount reversal
uh don't
don't open your chin like this you're
always talk and you always have your
hands in a guard position okay
uh so as i come around this is going to
open me up dc and open my target up and
that's where that guy yesterday punched
you and you stopped that move do you see
so
i'm more thinking about what is going on
so even even here i'll go and i'll make
contact because he goes to punch i can
stick to him as opposed to i'm now doing
this move out mom you're gonna get hit
so i'm covering up i'm sticking to what
i need to stick to and i'm paying
attention to those power lines so as i
come around and get this going
uh
i don't want to be here
i'm going to
be hiding in here
coming around
hide in here
and then just bad technique this is not
it this is where the guy pulled his arm
out and punched you again with that hand
so as you come around you want to make
sure you have a thumbless cap on the
back so he can't pull his arm out and
his thumb was capped here so he can't
pull his arm out too laterally later so
i'm here like this stuck in place
next thing
uh
he's gonna move so you can reinforce
this basic first
by trapping it before you bridge do you
see that so i don't want to go here he
just pulls it out and oh okay so
here trap and then go to
the bridge and then always goes on him
bring your center notch here bring your
center with you before you see
the administrative ending of that
posture
then the other point is you can start
this form
a right as he's getting on so you have
some sense
of musubi
with his techniques
[Music]
okay let's try and get those details in
because they were punishing you
yesterday
so the beginning of your movement is all
administrative okay that's why
he's just like this okay you saw
yesterday that the he has to provide the
opening for the movement okay
uh so for example
uh the way his body is now i would not
do that
this makes my leg vulnerable or he can
just grab my ankle
and pull it slowly
and he's gonna tweak go ahead you can do
it he's gonna tweak my lips my knee do
you see
uh so
but if you remember some of you were
grabbing really tight well see he walked
into it and just that little movement
already tightens it and takes the
balance dc
uh but when you learn the move
administratively this you that's part of
the move but you'll never get that in my
experience unless you violate jiu jitsu
principles
okay but he he'll put his foot he'll put
his foot there as as he's trying to do
something right he'll put there it is
right there and i got him do you see
okay that is more obvious when you're
doing elbow knee escape from the
administrative starting point okay
so uh
you're going to come up
get your frame
bridge
split your hands
out
boom
pinch
check so he doesn't come back down on
you
shrimp out the other way
and you go to elbow
if you try that administrative
[Music]
when someone's punching you
he goes your hands just left you open do
you see so this is not how you will find
it in the technique
but
the movement is
that
his knees one knee or so will be light
and his energy will be going in the
opposite direction
that you're going okay
so that's what you see here so i go one
i've made his knees light do you see and
then i'm going to push in this way and
i'll shrimp out the other way
okay
so for example where that comes into
play he goes to strike i take his
balance and you'll see this knee is like
you see so here's where i can come out
on that side
so as you're doing it administratively
make sure
that you get a knee
like
and that you're the one going around
things
as opposed
to moving him
so you're not going
that is not going to be
relatable to dynamic situation so i'm
moving myself
okay let's try it
go
you're gonna be in his life
you go around his knees
so in the administrative starting
position of each move
um
for example
as i said if he has his legs out there i
would not try to get that
so that is not the administrative
starting position for the mount reversal
if he is squeezing the hell out of me
that is not the administrative position
for the elbow knee so he does not do
that
got it
that said however
there are some common
mistakes
that you leave out because
you're confusing for example
the shrimping drill that you would do at
the beginning
with the technique
the technique obeys the rules of yin
space so you can only shrimp into yin
space if your normal shrimping pattern
takes you into yang space you're doing
it wrong
so in this maneuver i don't shrimp into
his other leg
you see that's not where it goes
so
you're going to shrimp
forward
until you feel the in space around the
leg you're shrimping around okay so you
don't shrimp into the other leg so whoa
forward there's the in space that's when
i come out
bring the leg
up
second mistake that tends to happen is
you can
especially on a guy who's static you can
kind of do all of this
with just your abdominals
and your knee hooks
on his hip bones but you will find that
very difficult to do
[Music]
again in more dynamic situations so
don't leave out
the
bottom foot
my feet are currently on the ground not
off the ground
on the ground
and pinching
and they're going to help me
turn my body so when i bring this leg
out
here
that foot
is going to stay on the ground and i use
to help me turn
as opposed to just my
knee
and try to do that i'll do it again it's
on the second foot
on the last shrimp
boom
leave that here put that foot on the
ground
and use the open guard with this knee
and use that foot
to turn your body
and now you have an open guard
before you bring the knee out
okay or the foot out
all right
get those two concepts going only shrimp
into the in space
leave that last pivot foot in the middle
of their legs
use the open guard with the knee rather
than trying to use it as a hook for your
shrimping maneuver
so again in like a competition setting
it it would be fine to
take your hands away from here and put
them here but not in a more live setting
like yesterday okay so
um
as i do this maneuver
i'm going to start
modifying it closer to what i would have
to do if he's striking me okay so i have
the same rules i'm going to use that
same shield as i go
and i don't break it as much as the
administrative forum requires
so i'm not breaking it
boom you see how my hands will come
right back into that guard position and
the pain to pay attention to his power
lines okay so i'm heading over here on
the outside of this power line until i
get
a trap on one of his arms
and i can do the same thing as he's
about to go on me as i did in the mount
reversal so it has some sort of live
component to it
okay
as opposed to
[Music]
this isn't gonna work you're gonna get
punched everywhere okay
start bringing in
i gotta pay attention to the power lines
i gotta be ready to trap okay try it
again the next one is very very similar
only uh
i make sure i come over here okay
so it's gonna start the same so there's
no point in going to this administrative
starting point with my frame here i try
to keep myself as long as i can as i
bridge and then duck into here okay
and i turn myself on my
diagonal i don't want to be on my side
because i don't want to expose my back
to him okay
so i'm on a diagonal here
and
this arm stops him from pushing me down
and this arm stops him from coming back
on top okay i'm in this position there's
there's an integrity to this position
i'm not here like this
locked out like this okay
and it's from here
that
i now
capitalize upon that light and knee just
by hooking this and grabbing it
and bringing it back and i come around
it
and now you have
elbow knee on the other side
so key
it's here
boom
making myself
with a positional integrity
lightening that knee as a result
up
to hook
and then it gets lighter
and i move around it
and i go to the other side
and now use that same final foot to
pivot
he's on i can do the timing
all right
let's go only the first part is
partially new okay
okay the fourth one so this was a
four-part dilemma we were using
yesterday it wasn't a sparring drill it
it wasn't even a flow drill it was just
hey work with these dilemmas
uh these dilemma aspects that's all you
got i only gave you those four that's
what you're supposed to work with okay
you weren't supposed to do whatever you
want to see how these interrelate with
each other
and we introduced the spontaneous
element of if he's going to be punching
at you as you work the dilemma okay
so um
they build on each other
as you can see for example
in this last technique we just did
uh the second half is the second
technique we did okay and the first half
the very first half the bridge was the
part of the first technique okay and so
likewise the force technique is going to
use the bridge in a way very similar to
the last technique okay so we can start
from the administrative position
uh
and i'm going to bridge him onto my
hands
and then
this leg is light
and i use transfer his weight to my
hands as i shrimp out that light
laying there and then we just stopped in
this position of course you have your
heel hooks and your reversals and things
like we just stopped here to work the
dilemma aspects okay
so
same thing
uh don't break your guard anymore then
you have to
well
you're out
you should not feel his weight
at all it's a transfer
of his body
into that position okay
um and then
same thing
yesterday some of you tried this move
when the guy's weight was either
supporting his balance or he was
pressuring you
that's not when you would do this move
uh it's more when he goes up to punch
you that's when you do that move so he
goes up to punch you and that's when
that move comes out you see that so
uh emphasizing even more the point
that you're not muscling him
so don't muscle him now
figure out
how to get
that to be effortless by moving into the
in space
and using
his energy his mass
in a way where you're not actually
lifting it and pushing it okay
trying
okay so
uh
again a beginner mistake is
not really in a sophisticated way
understanding yin and yang
yin and yang
yin is not always empty space okay
yen is always relative to yang
so in the second move
i went into empty space in the fourth
move i go into yid space okay so what do
i mean by that as i go to do the
maneuver
i don't want to try to go around his leg
like the first move
as i go to do the maneuver
boom i move into
this leg i'm moving into that leg the
leg is relative yin to my movement
because all his weight is here so
wherever i feel that leg
cool that's what i pushed into that leg
to get out of that position okay
watch that you're not feeling
for the empty space
and you're trying to go like this as
you're never going you didn't get the
leg okay
feel where his leg is boom
move right into that leg position and
then you'll have your stuff okay